>>> TONIGHT, INTELLIGENCE FROM
TOP SECRET U.S. SPY PLANES IS
PROVIDING STARTLING DETAILS
ABOUT CHINA'S SPY OPERATIONS.
WE ARE LEARNING THAT IMAGES
TAKEN OF THE SPY BALLOONS BY
HIGH ALTITUDE YOUTUBE PLANES
SHOW IN DETAIL FIVE ANTENNAS AND
HUGE SOLAR PANELS, THE KIND OF
TECHNOLOGY THAT GAVE THE CHINESE
NOT JUST THE ABILITY TO LISTEN
TO U.S. COMMUNICATIONS AND TO
PINPOINT EXACTLY WHERE THEY WERE
COMING FROM, WHO THEY WERE
COMING FROM.
ALL OF THIS ESPECIALLY ALARMING
AS THE BALLOON PASSED OVER
SENSITIVE MILITARY SITES BEFORE
THE U.S. AIR FORCE SHOT IT DOWN
OFF THE SOUTH CAROLINA COAST.
AND OF COURSE WE KNOW THERE HAVE
BEEN OTHER BALLOONS WHERE THAT
ONE CAME FROM.
THESE NEW DETAILS COME AS CHINA
IS FORCEFULLY PUSHING BACK
AGAINST PRESIDENT BIDEN'S VERY
PUBLIC CRITICISM OF PRESIDENT XI
JINPING AT THE STATE OF THE
UNION.
"OUTFRONT" NOW, WILL RIPLEY WHO
THE ABOUT IS IN TAIWAN.
>> Reporter: FIERY NEW RHETORIC
FROM CHINA ESCALATING THE
SUSPECTED SPY BALLOON SCANDAL.
BEIJING BLASTING PRESIDENT JOE
BIDEN FOR CRITICIZING CHINESE
PRESIDENT XI JINPING.
>> CAN YOU THINK OF ANY OTHER
WORLD LEADER WHO WOULD TRADE
PLACES WITH XI JINPING?
NOT A JOKE.
CAN YOU THINK OF ANY WHO WOULD?
I CAN'T THINK OF ONE.
THIS MAN HAS ENORMOUS PROBLEMS.
>> Reporter: CHINA SAYS BIDEN'S
REMARKS ARE HIGHLY IRRESPONSIBLE
AND VIOLATE BASIC DIPLOMATIC
PROTOCOLS.
PROBLEMS COMPLICATED BY A
GROWING PILE OF EVIDENCE, PIECES
OF THE DOWNED BALLOON PULLED
FROM THE SEA OFF THE CAROLINA
COAST.
PROOF THE PENTAGON SAYS CHINA'S
WEATHER BALLOON CLAIM IS NOTHING
BUT HOT AIR.
A CHINESE FOREIGN MINISTRY
SPOKESMAN SAYS "I HAVE NO
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT AMERICA'S CLAIM
THAT THIS BALLOON IS PART OF A
FLEET.
I THINK IT COULD BE PART OF THE
INFORMATION AND PUBLIC OPINION
WAR THAT THE U.S. IS WAGING
AGAINST CHINA.
THE INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY CAN
SEE CLEARLY WHO IS THE WORLD'S
LARGEST ESPIONAGE AND
SURVEILLANCE COUNTRY."
>> I CAN SAY AYE SURE YOU THIS
WAS NOT FOR CIVILIAN PURPOSES.
WE ARE 100% CLEAR ABOUT THAT.
>> THERE IS THAT.
>> Reporter: THE U.S. LINKED THE
BALLOON TO A VAST CHINESE
MILITARY SURVEILLANCE PROGRAM, A
GROWING LIST OF GLOBAL BALLOON
SIGHTINGS, AND QUESTIONS.
THE U.S. BELIEVES MANY BALLOONS
ARE LAUNCHED FROM CHINA'S HAINAN
ISLAND, WHERE A U.S. SPY PLANE
MADE AN EMERGENCY LANDING IN
2001.
CHINA TOOK THREE MONTHS TO
INVESTIGATE BEFORE RETURNING THE
PLANE IN PIECES.
NOW CHINA IS ATTACKING THE U.S.
FOR SHOOTING DOWN ITS BALLOON
AND SENDING THE PIECES TO AN FBI
LAB.
THE SPOKESMAN SAYS THE U.S.
INSISTS ON USING FORCE TO ATTACK
CHINESE UNMANNED CIVILIAN AIR
SHIPS WHICH SERIOUSLY VIOLATES
INTERNATIONAL PRACTICE AND SETS
A HORRIBLE PRECEDENT.
U.S. DEFENSE SECRETARY LLOYD
AUSTIN ASKED FOR A PHONE CALL
WITH CHINA'S DEFENSE MINISTER.
BEIJING BLUNTLY DECLINED.
>> AND IT'S A PRECARIOUS MOMENT.
I KNOW YOU HAVE BEEN LEARNING
THAT XI JINPING WAS DIRECTLY
INVOLVED IN THIS PROGRAM.
AND IN FACT, THIS PROGRAM IS NOT
NEW.
AND IN FACT, BALLOONS FLYING
OVER THE U.S. SPYING FROM CHINA
IS NOT NEW.
BUT JUST HOW MUCH DID XI JINPING
KNOW?
>> YEAH, I MEAN, YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT MORE THAN 40 COUNTRIES
ACROSS FIVE CONTINENTS,
ACCORDING TO A SENIOR STATE
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL.
>> WOW.
>> THESE BALLOONS HAVE GATHERED
INTELLIGENCE.
THIS PROGRAM HAS BEEN GOING ON
WITH PRESIDENT XI'S DIRECT
KNOWLEDGE.
HOWEVER, LAWMAKERS BRIEF ON THIS
HAVE BEEN TOLD THAT THIS
PARTICULAR BALLOON AT THIS
PARTICULAR TIME MAY HAVE BEEN